President Trump says China could have
stopped the corona virus from spreading
to other countries China's foreign
ministry says claims that the virus
escaped from a lab are quote fabricated
out of nothing then Tracey is at the
White House been the president's view of
the Chinese response has really changed
significantly
it sure has you know back in January and
February President Trump was praising
China for doing a good job and for being
transparent he now says that was in part
to get the trade deal done and that it's
possible that China intentionally
allowed the corona virus to spread now
here at the White House on Thursday
President Trump also said that he has
seen credible evidence that the virus
actually originated in a lab in Wuhan
China but he gave no further details
earlier Thursday the Office of the
Director of National Intelligence said
that it agrees with the scientific
consensus that the Kovach 19 virus was
not man-made or genetically modified but
it is still investigating now as the
president lays blame on China he is
praising the efforts of himself and his
administration on Thursday vice
president Mike Pence toured a ventilator
factory in Indiana he was notably
wearing a mask after receiving backlash
earlier this week for not wearing one
when he was at the Mayo Clinic now
president Trump says that he has no
problem wearing a mask when he travels
to Arizona next week to tour a factory
that's making medical supplies the
president is going to get out of the
White House for the first time since
late March he's actually heading to Camp
David for the weekend tony benn thank
you very much